David is next David's in Rhode Island hi
David welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Dave and Rachel what is going on Oh guys
great brother how can we help oh my god
I can't believe it I just found out of
like you guys literally a week ago on
Facebook
and have been non-stop listening to you
yes I've been doing everything wrong
apparently and the accountants at slice
so I own two businesses very successful
companies thank God and and I'm a
full-time police officer based off of
this coronavirus that's going on my
income has dropped significantly from my
companies as from a salary standpoint
based off of ensuring that my employees
get paid versus myself getting paid the
thing that I'm struggling with right now
is I own several properties including
our residents that my wife and I live in
and I have been so focused on paying off
our home residents when we first bought
it doubling our mortgage payments every
single month and it was my highest loan
and I I really from everything that I've
listened to with you guys I don't in the
way really have so much personal debt
it's all either investment properties or
business debt and yeah well let me ask
you let me ask you this I don't think
you're wrong I think you've done the
right thing if I gather where you are if
you have zero debt other than rentals
and your home is that what you're
telling me no no God no I wish I wish I
thought you said you had no personal
debt you're rentals and outside the only
threat that I have personally is my home
everything else is investment and
business debt okay what kind of business
debt do you have all right so unlike
equipment it's roughly about 90 grand
and
and as far as real estate that goes yeah
real estates different okay all real
estate goes in what we call baby step
six
now your business debt you personally
signed four so I put all that in baby
step two so I'd clear all of your debt
except for real estate debt first then I
would clear your home okay now here's
why now quick here's why think about
where we are right now in this mess if
you didn't have the $90,000 equipment
loan but you only had real estate loans
you'd be better off right 100% and then
if your house next step is if your house
was paid for right now and no equipment
debt and all you had was rental debt
you'd be a whole lot better off right
100% because if you're gonna lose some
you don't lose your home right if you
toss the bank keys on one of those
rentals your life doesn't change much
but you got a paid-for home sitting
there but you don't toss them the keys
on your home and so now that I ask you
another question in regards to that mhm
so based off of your snowball effect
right I've been advised from my
accountant so out of those equipment
loans three of them there's zero percent
or in your snowball effect it's go with
the lowest amount against moving in and
I wanted to do that two years ago I was
talked out of doing that yeah your
accountant with your mountains isn't
paying your bills right now hundred
percent yeah you are man you're the guy
that wants to get rid of him so yeah I
would clear the 91st on this debt
snowball and baby step two and then I
would work on your house and then your
other see how this works how much piece
you you can kind of feel it yes when I
wall seen it yeah absolutely
when we have had that question for 30
years what up how first the rental or my
home I was your home cuz if things go
bad but who would have thought they
would ever be sitting where we're
sitting there you go